[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute zeige ich euch wie man diese weiß
hier machen kann
ein regenbogen eis gerade jetzt wenn es
draußen zu warm ist da habe ich echt
immer lust auf was erfrischendes nass
kaltes die kinder vor allem die wollen
jeden tag ein eis essen und ich habe
echt ein problem damit jeden tag was
süßes auf den tisch zu stellen
ich persönlich es auch nicht so gerne
kuchen und torten war ab und zu ist okay
aber für jeden tag finde ich echt
einfach zu viel
daher könnt ihr dieses super zubereiten
denn es ist komplett ohne zugesetzten
zucker und besteht aus obst aus gemüse
teilweise sogar aus früchten und in
whistler joghurt und dieses eis kann
jeder ganz einfach zu hause selber
nachmachen und ich habe in jeder schicht
joghurt und banane als grundzutaten
damit das eis schön cremig wird und die
anderen schichten die ergeben sich dann
mit anderen früchten die blaue schicht
ergänzt sich dann noch mit ananas und
blaue lebensmittelfarbe die lackschicht
mit blaubeeren und ananas die rote
schicht mit johannisbeeren und himbeeren
die orangene schicht mit orangen und
mango die gelbe schicht mit ananas ruhig
die grüne schicht mit kiwi und ananas
also ihr braucht im prinzip nur einen
mixer stabmixer oder sona mixa und jetzt
werden alle zutaten einzel natürlich
also jede schicht für sich miteinander
püriert also fange ich an mit der blauen
sicht
das habe ich erst mal das obst püriert
und gebe jetzt nach dem joghurt und die
blaue lebensmittelfarbe dazu
und das ist auch die einzige geschichte
bei der ich jetzt lebensmittelfarbe
hände denn blaue früchte gibt es nicht
also ich hab zwar bleiben aber die sind
eher lila also nehme ich jetzt hier
einfach ein schönes blau eine
lebensmittelfarbe ohne azofarbstoffe und
hatte dann auch eine schöne blaue
schicht
[Musik]
und bevor ich jetzt die nächste schicht
mixe werde ich jetzt schon mal diese
schicht in meiner form verteilen ich
nehme jetzt eine ice form ihr könnt aber
auch noch in form nehmen oder auch eine
kastenform oder eine beliebige
kunststoff form mit frischhaltefolie
ausgleichen und dann das eis einführen
also wenn ihr keine kleinen form habt
könnte ein großes eis machen um später
einfach in scheiben schneiden und zum
besseren einfüllen nehme ich jetzt
einfach einen gefrierbeutel den stufe
ich über ein glas kommt jetzt die masse
rein
dann fordern eine spitze wegschneiden
damit hilfe dieses spritzbeutel füllen
und wirklich nur ganz wenig so dass
später alle sechs schichten reinpassen
und bevor jetzt die nächste schicht
draufkommt kommt das eis erst mal ins
gefrierfach damit es friert und die
schichten sich nicht zu sehr vermissen
ich stelle jetzt einfach alle
farbschichten nacheinander her bei der
grünen spricht fällt mir noch einen
entweder können die ein bisschen spinat
nehmen oder mangold spinat habe ich
jetzt nicht da aber ich habe noch mango
und im garten den hole ich noch dazu
damit ich einfach ein schönes intensives
grün habe die farbschichten werden jetzt
hergestellt und dann fühle ich immer ein
bisschen schicht nochmal nachlass das
einfrieren und dann kommt erst die
nächste schicht
wir haben ja mangold angepflanzt also
nehme ich jetzt hier einfach die grünen
blätter ich habe auch mangold mit rot
die will ich aber nicht ich würde
schönes grün und zu fuß hier einfach die
jungen schönen blätter ab
bei der lisa schicht nämlich übrigens
gefrorene blau werden denn die sind
innen und außen blau
meist bekommt man nämlich im supermarkt
oder auch im garten nur diese
kulturheidelbeeren und die sind in ein
weißes recht schade ich habe ich die
bessere farbe
die erste schicht ist gefroren jetzt
nehme ich die nächste schicht und ich
schickte das eis so dass ich zuerst blau
habt dann lila rot orange gelb und grün
das ist so der farbverlauf und schneidet
auch jetzt eine spitze ab kommt also
diese schicht rauch und dann
nacheinander nach dem frieren immer die
nächste
doch die letzte schicht drauf das ist
jetzt bei mir die grüne schicht ein
bisschen was habe ich jetzt noch übrig
ist aber nicht schlimm denn das ist im
prinzip ein leckerer smoothie den mann
so auftreten kann
und jetzt kommt hier der deckel drauf
ihr dürft auch nicht warten bis zum
schluss bis alles durch die freude ist
denn die städte müssen hier ja noch rein
und dann kommt es in den gefrierschrank
und muss einfach komplett durch schweren
am besten über nacht oder eben auch für
ein paar stunden
und so ist natürlich ein bisschen
aufwendig mit den einzelnen schichten
aber ich finde es später einfach
superschön
daher lohnt sich der aufwand
da darf man nicht schon wieder eis
gerungs berater ja ja ja ja gesagt mein
problem ist sogar gesagt habe ist mein
problems nicht zucker mein problem meine
frau habe ich gesagt und das andere ist
im nächsten leben werde ich
wahrscheinlich den fitness bloggerin
heiraten ja im nächsten leben nicht
jetzt jetzt ist alles nur die nächsten
leben heiratet nicht im nächsten leben
in einem live frau nein was mach ich da
rauskomme
das ist jetzt nämlich was denkst du wenn
du das siehst du aus dem friedhof okay
was denkst du wenn du die farbe grün
siehst ich denke an kiwi denken
[Musik]
ok bei mais gibt es ein ganz ganz
besonderes geheimnis ja welches
geheimnis von eis ist das muss gut
aussehen kann auch schmecken und zwar
ist es nicht so wir müssen mal eins
machen die mich ein eis nehmen und
schmelzen lassen und dann müsste ich mal
muss sich flüssig trinken er werde 1
merken es ist so voller zucker und das
merkst du aber nicht weil es kalt ist
und zwar der reiter kälte verliert sich
hat der zucker also als ein der fotograf
verrät sich aber die süße deswegen muss
man als grund machte etwas süßer
abschmecken ja und wenn du echt eis
schmilzt ist echt ex-polizisten gemüse
isst du bist vegan
ich habe joghurt strin daher ist nicht
ganz vergangen aber man kann ja auch
vegan joghurt nehmen die form übrigens
kurz unter heißes wasser halten anders
herum dann geht es einfach nicht glauben
blaubär richtig welche oben ist blau
das sagen und nicht die oberste schicht
ist gefärbt denn es gibt keine früchte
kein obst gemüse was so blau ist okay so
muss ich kenne ich nicht
deswegen habe ich ganz oben
lebensmittelfarbe drin aber die zweite
schicht ist blau wäre das lila aber auch
kein zucker zugefügt weil ich nicht gut
das ist eine coole die schiffe für pizza
schmeckt immer noch süß aber nicht zu
arg süß und das banana ja es ist eine
richtig coole geschichte man da kann
noch ein kind auch mal so 341 am tag
essen und er ist ja nur fruchtpüree also
eigentlich smoothies gefrorene smoothies
smokey eyes und ich glaube dieses einzig
echter renner auf jeder auf jedem
kindergeburtstag auf jeder kinderparty
ich glaube wir sind jetzt dieses eis
hinstellt und dann noch so ein ice aus
der waffe sondern gekauft ist und ich
glaube kinder greifen dazu herr schütze
blaue zurück ja ja auch nicht so ganz
aber ja also falls es nach machen wollt
ist zwar zeitaufwendig durch die
einzelnen schichten aber es lohnt sich
auf jeden fall
und wenn ihr sagt ihr wollt weniger
schichten weniger farbe man kann also
jemand zehn und zwanzig stück machen und
mittig kids davon 23 studientag zu geben
ist keine schöne abkühlung
also viel spaß und noch mal bis zum
nächsten mal
ja kommt dass die jungs das machen wir
daraus ja ok aber glücklich macht ihr
fotos oder mit größter sorge fotos und
daniel danach kriegen sie es
[Musik]